it can be done it has been done I think
it would Elevate the quality of the show
having to you know figure that out and
how to you know extract emotion from an
emotionless helmet but we like like Mari
said I've cried at many a Halo moment
and I'm just like no it can be done it
can absolutely be done so yeah that's
sad that they going that route I
understand that it is his own thing and
and they need to appeal it have it
appeal to a broader audience which is
why these decisions are made
but n i i i to me that's what I liked
kind of about the the second trailer
right even though yes it is it is Lady
Gaga talking over the trailer about
she's gonna bring your ruin at the end
of the day human Covenant the Fall Of
Reach I if they handle a Fall Of Reach
properly if they handle the Fall Of
Reach properly I'll be happy